estoy súper emocionada para que hoy
vamos a estar viendo un vídeo sobre el
proceso de ovulación creo que le va a
gustar mucho este vídeo lo explica
completamente perfecto y me encanta la
animación voy a empezar
[Música]
la ovulación es una parte del ciclo
menstrual en la que el ovario libera un
óvulo maduro o huevo dentro del ovario
hay cientos de miles de folículos cada
folículo es una bola hueca de células
con un óvulo y maduro en el centro
el típico ciclo menstrual de 28 días
comienza el primer día del sangrado
menstrual
durante los primeros 7 días y antes el
vídeo me encanta que empezó al principio
enseñando el cuerpo como para el útero y
cómo es que está en el pelvis podemos
ver los tubos de falopio y también los
ovarios podemos ver la relación cercana
de los tubos de falopio junto con los
ovarios también quiero mencionar que es
que dijeron que el ciclo menstrual
usualmente es de 28 días y si muchas
mujeres tienen un sangrado cada 28 días
pero también es normal si el ciclo
menstrual es entre 21 a 35 días lo que
quiero decir es que si tiene sangrado
cada 21 días o cada 35 días o cada 28 o
cada 30 o vasos es normal durante los
primeros 7 días del ciclo algunos
folículos comienzan a crecer al mismo
tiempo estos folículos que están
madurando segregan hormonas estrógenos
en el flujo sanguíneo para preparar las
paredes del útero para el embarazo
alrededor del día 7 todos los folículos
excepto 1 dejan de crecer y comienzan a
degenerarse
y ella hablaron del día 7 vamos a
repasar rapidito el día 1 del ciclo
menstrual es el primer día que tiene
sangrado este folículo dominante
continúa creciendo y alimenta el óvulo
en desarrollo dentro del mismo
alrededor del día 12 el folículo segrega
una gran cantidad de estrógeno en el
flujo sanguíneo
cuando el estrógeno llega al hipotálamo
y la glándula pituitaria del cerebro la
parte anterior o delantera de la
glándula pituitaria libera un gran
volumen de hormona luteinizante en el
flujo sanguíneo
alrededor del día 14 la hormona
luteinizante hace que el folículo sufra
un crecimiento acelerado y repentino
justo antes de la ovulación el óvulo se
desprende del interior del folículo el
folículo protuberante libera químicos
haciendo que una de las dos trompas de
falopio se mueva más cerca del folículo
y lo rodee
[Música]
lo quiero para el rapidito porque me
encanta me encantan que explicaron todo
también la relación entre las hormonas
que hace el ovario cómo se afecta las
partes en el cerebro y cómo después de
cerebro también te comunica con los
ovarios es un proceso bien delicado para
nosotros tener un ciclo menstrual
regular hay muchas partes que tienen que
correr junto los ovarios el cerebro la
matriz el tubo de falopio son muchas
partes con un proceso bien delicado y me
encanta el vídeo y como lo está
explicando
el folículo se hincha hasta que se abre
de golpe expulsando al óvulo y al
líquido del folículo en la cavidad
abdominal
en consecuencia la fibra y minúsculas
proyecciones al final de la trompa de
falopio pasa rápidamente por el lugar de
la ovulación y recoge al óvulo los
cilios microscópicos sobre la superficie
de la filia transportan al óvulo hacia
la entrada de la trompa de falopio
dentro de las paredes de la trompa de
falopio las contracciones musculares
empujan suavemente al óvulo hacia el
útero después de la ovulación el óvulo
vive entre 12 y 24 horas por lo tanto
para querer o para lo hay rapidito
porque escucharon eso el óvulo solamente
vive entre 12 a 24 horas fue mucho
tiempo que ese óvulo está vivo como
estamos hablando cuando una mujer está
intentando quedar embarazada es un
proceso que es bien corto 12 24 horas
atrás es tan importante que una mujer
esté consciente de su ciclo menstrual
cuando le va a bajar cuáles son los días
más fértiles cómo es que va a pasar los
procesos de población porque ahí después
vamos a ver cuáles son los días más
fértiles y cuándo empezar a tener
relaciones vamos a seguir lo tanto para
que una mujer quede embarazada el óvulo
debe ser fecundado por un espermatozoide
masculino durante ese periodo sí no
fecundado el óvulo se disuelve afuera y
es eliminado junto con las paredes del
útero durante la menstruación
me encantó el vídeo lo hicieron perfecto
lo explicaron todo perfecto también me
gusta que estos vídeos son un poquito
más cortitos o es más fácil poder verlo
yo también soy alguien que aprende con
muchos visuales vídeos o me gustó mucho
cómo hicieron el vídeo
yo espero que ustedes también les haya
gustado el vídeo y que hayan aprendido
algo nuevo este vídeo fue una
colaboración entre el new y smart
comedia y mi canal de youtube eibar en
mi canal de youtube que ha creado un
espacio en donde yo puedo hablar de
diferentes temas 6 acá está la salud de
la mujer voy a dejar el 20 mi canal de
youtube en la descripción bueno espero
que tengan un lindo día siempre recuerde
enseñarle amor a todo el mundo que está
alrededor los quiero mucho los veo en mi
próximo vídeo